doodle did a survey of more than I
believe 1500 professionals and what they
found is on average people in this rule
spend more than five hours in scheduling
meetings just back and forth in trying
to find the right time imagine five eyes
every person spending every week to
schedule meetings you're listening to
the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen Hughes inga in a world where
productivity is paramount and only a
handful of people have personal
assistants many of us are frustrated by
the amount of time we spend in meetings
and worse the amount of time we spend
planning scheduling and rescheduling
those meetings fortunately dr. Pamela
Bhattacharya a principle applied
scientist in Microsoft Outlook group
wants to turn your email into your own
personal assistant and a smart one at
that today dr. Bhattacharya tells us all
about scheduler Microsoft's virtual
personal assistant and how her team is
using machine learning to put the I in
intelligent PDAs she also talks about
how understanding different levels of
automation can help us set the right
expectations for our experience with AI
and explains how in the workplace of the
future we might actually achieve more by
doing less that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Pamela Bhattacharya welcome to the
podcast thank you thank you for having
me that's a great name does it mean
something no I don't think it doesn't
meaning I bet it does somewhere but
maybe I don't know yeah that's your
homework did this whole family tree for
our entire family so yeah I think she
might know I'll get her on the podcast
next well let's start by getting you
situated for our audience you're a
principle applied scientist at Microsoft
and you're currently working in the
Outlook product group mm-hmm
I'll have you tell us that story of a
little bit later but first I want you to
tell us more generally about what
excites you about the work you do and
what gets you up in the morning I think
I really believe in Microsoft's core
mission which is to empower every
individual and every organization in the
world and I think productivity is the
core to it and I think after working on
the space for you know almost four years
now it seems counterintuitive but in
terms of productivity doing less is
achieving more finding that right
balance is very important and how we
empower people to find their own balance
because everybody's different their
scenarios are different it's all
contextual how we help people find that
balance for themselves I think is what
excites me and keeps me going I want to
go in on doing less is achieving more
yeah can you unpack it a little bit yeah
it was very personal for me as I was
progressing in my career at Microsoft I
was working on different projects and
even within the same you know team I was
trying to have impact on different
things and then you know I had my son
and suddenly the life world balance you
know what it meant
changed but I felt like I still wanted
to do impactful work and I felt like the
only way I could continue to do
impactful work is by choosing problems
that are really really important and
doing only one or two of them rather
than doing eight or nine of them which
probably I was doing earlier and I
like I became more productive by making
that conscious decision almost every day
I have to push myself to think like you
know what can I cut too what can I not
do and still achieve what I want to
achieve and I think that's where we can
help build tech for people to make them
more conscious and aware of that
I want to hover at ten thousand feet for
a minute and talk somewhat
philosophically about a pretty big topic
and it's the future of work and it was a
theme of Emma Starr's faculty summit
last year and the premise which I quote
from the conference overview is new
advances in computing are transforming
existing work and productivity paradigms
tomorrow we will work in more places
faster more collaboratively and our
output will be ever more thoughtful
creative and impactful that's a big
assertion from your perspective and this
is just your perspective but what's hope
and what's hype about that statement I
think the hope is that if we can all
collaborate in a way that makes us
individually productive and globally
productive just to give an example so on
days and maybe just coding and I feel
productive at the end of the day because
I finished my feature right and on some
days I don't even write a line of code
and all I did was brainstorm with other
people you know help unblock others you
know whiteboard and try to find
solutions and I still feel productive
under the day because you know I did so
much which cannot be really measured in
terms of lines of code or you know what
I delivered how many presentations
nothing like that but I feel that one of
the major challenges in the product with
this pace is coming up a very tangible
way to measure how productive I was or
an organization was you know we have
productivity scores but at the end of
the day how do I feel about it how does
my team feel about it I feel that there
is a gap in what we are doing and what
we are measuring and how that all ties
back as a feedback loop for example and
how we keep improving I've been
fascinated by the diversity of research
interests among the scientists here and
many of them have self-identified I'm
not even kidding they have there's a
research grid where you're either like
Neil
Bohr who was all about basic research or
your Thomas Edison who was all about
Applied Research or your Louis Pasteur
who's some mix of applied and basic but
where do you self-identify on that grid
what kinds of projects fall in your
wheelhouse and what value do you think
your work brings to the world I think
it's definitely in the played quadrant I
feel one thing that I really enjoy is
problem-solving and it could be that I
come up with the most simplest solution
that works or it could be I worked on it
and it's very complicated and it's very
layered so on and so forth so for me the
complexity of the solution doesn't
change my approach to the problems if it
works it works
you know that's what I care most about
and we can talk later about you know my
journey in calendar not help but after I
joined Microsoft I moved to a team which
was just starting I was literally the
first hire on the team and I didn't
think about being in a start-up
environment or being in that culture or
doing something you know grounds up but
that was a ground sub initiative that we
were taking at Microsoft to transform
customer support experience and I just
loved the experience you know having a
small team having much more connection
with the leaders and the managers and
making sure I had really understand what
they are trying to achieve and how I am
aligned with their goals and so on and
so forth and just the agility of it
that's when I realized that these are
the kind of incubation teams that I
really find making more impact I enjoy
being in incubation efforts and taking
them to completion
well let's talk about one specific
incubation project that you've just
mentioned it's getting a lot of
attention right now and it was called as
you said calendar dot help yeah but it's
now called scheduler and you referred to
it as both I'll frame it as a personal
assistant for people who don't have
people before we get into the specifics
on the technology set the problem for us
what was the pain point that prompted
the project in other words why do we
need it you might be familiar with
doodle which is our online scheduling
tool right and doodle did a survey of
more than I believe 1500 professionals
and what they found is on average people
in this rule spend more than five hours
in scheduling meetings just back and
forth in trying to find the right time
imagine five eyes every person spending
every week to schedule meetings and as
you know even VP's at Microsoft they
have their own executive admins that
manage their calendars manage their time
write dealt with them so how do we solve
this and the funny part is that before I
join the project you know I always
thought it was scheduling a meeting but
in reality a meeting has a life cycle
you initiate a meeting after multiple
back-and-forth it gets scheduled and
most often not not it means to be
rescheduled right our people need to be
added or you know you name it like you
know it has a life on its own really
does a meeting get scheduled it happens
and it's done I can't remember the last
time so I feel like that's a complexity
it brings to it so it's not like once
and done you know you don't know how
many times you have to iterate over it
okay so everything you've just said I
bet it's gonna resonate with everyone in
our audience except the people who have
people and so that pain point is real
I'm just nodding my head no one can see
it but I'm going yep absolutely so tell
us about your solution which is now
called scheduler it's an intelligent
personal digital assistant eye PDA for
those TLA fans and it brings recent
advances in machine learning and that's
the intelligence to the field of PDAs
personal digital assistants so I'm gonna
let you run with this because you do a
fantastic job of explaining it but don't
be afraid to get technical okay so a
little bit of background so scheduler
started with the idea of building a gig
economic platform for executives
assistants and that's where it started
infused lives and soon they realized
that of all jobs that executive admins
need to do scheduling is the pain point
like we discussed earlier
so essentially scheduler started with
being this human and AI hybrid platform
to
enable scheduling much more easier so as
an user I can offload it to the
intelligent assistant and they take care
of it
so the user experience is really very
much like how you see our VP's interact
so say I'm having an email conversation
with my VP Gaurav and you know at some
point he might say hey okay let's just
meet and chat you know it's getting
complicated
and then here's CC his admin crystal and
just say crystal can you find us a time
and he might give more constraints find
us a time next week or find us a time
and add somebody else who is not on the
thread right and then on what crystal
does Christos job is to understand those
constraints and schedule a meeting now
let me get to the technical part so the
assistant or the service gets its email
but this email contains a lot of
information that's not relevant to
scheduling right I you know say we
talked about the project we talked about
deadlines we talked about other meetings
but to the assistant you're very
specifically saying about scheduling one
meeting so the first technical problem
that we solve was given a document how
do you find out what are the relevant
sentences for a task at hand
so here the task at hand is scheduling
so this was a ranking you know algorithm
that we came up with in finding relevant
sentences for that okay so that's step
one step two once you have found the
relevant sentences then it's about
understanding intent what are you trying
to do oki is trying to schedule one
meeting recommend meeting an online
meeting a phone call a lunch because all
those will define how you choose the
time so what you do with it right and
it's very contextual so you might say
let's have a lunch meeting right so then
the assistant needs to understand that
okay I can only look between times say
between 11:30 and 1 because nobody has
lunch either a 10 or at 4:00 right so so
understanding the context understanding
what are the constraints that apply to
this meeting you know your intent is the
second step and the third step is now
what do I do with this right how do i
process it in a way and what is my final
outcome so for example one of the
outcomes could be okay I say a recruiter
is trying to schedule a meeting with a
candidate
assistant doesn't have access to the
candidates calendar right so they have
to reach out just like an admin would
reach out and say hey Pamela is
available times X Y Z you know does any
of this work and then reply again in
absolute natural language saying either
yes all that works or no doesn't work
how about something else or they might
say I can do the first and the third
right or you know even more complicated
it becomes like if say we give three
options to on Tuesday and one on
Thursday they just say Tuesday works so
now we have to do the job of mapping
Tuesday with the options and you know so
it's a whole other complicated system
that's out there now and then again you
know as I said earlier meeting has a
life cycle so it might get rescheduled
you might need to cancel it you might
need to add more people you might need
to drop people because not everybody is
available there's no mutual availability
so on and so forth so that's one layer
of natural language understanding you
know marching interpreting and then
there's another layer of preferences
right personalizing the assistant for
you because if I say hypothetically had
a human admin they would know what times
I prefer right I might not be a morning
person at all I know that they would
know that you know over time but if I
have a meeting with somebody saying MSR
India they wouldn't hesitate to schedule
a meeting at 8:00 a.m. because you know
that's a more human time to have a
meeting right for everyone involved
exactly so again how do you have
personalization but how do you add
context to it okay so that you know it's
the best of all worlds
[Music]
before we get into the open problems
which you've alluded to which involve
personalization disambiguation entity
extraction intent negation all of that
stuff and I want to talk to you about
that first tell us what this product
does well how does it work it's very
seamless it's essentially a similar
experience to having a human admin where
you just see see the admin which in this
case is an email address got an ad
calendar daughter and the service takes
over from there and anything any new
instructions you need to add you just
send an email to your assistant ok so
the assistant is actually an intelligent
agent and the intelligent agent is going
to try to do all of the things that a
human would yeah yeah let's talk a
little bit about the problems that are
still out there that you're working on
yes it's still working on a trade and
it's a mixture so initially we look at
your calendar and we try to understand
what are your meeting behaviors and
preferences right but then those all
change over time and again those have
you know layers of context with it right
so I might have morning meetings twice a
week but those are only for meeting with
people in India is there MSR team there
or I might have late meetings and that
might be only for meetings with the
should--so team right and then during
the day I might have one-on-ones
clustered but say other technical
meetings might have more space between
them because I might need to come from
one meeting you know just take some time
out for myself and then have a next
meeting so how do you balance all these
things out and that's where we are you
know trying out a reinforcement learning
to personalize these recommendations
based on the context you know so that's
one area that we are investing in one of
the most interesting areas that you
talked to me about was negation and how
a machine deals with what a human can
understand really easily why don't you
explain that yeah so the other
complicated part of the entity
extraction that I talked to you about
earlier is how the same semantics can be
expressed in so many different ways so
for example I might say hey I can meet
you Gretchen next week except Thursday
well
that resolves to exactly the same time
range if you will versus if I had said I
can meet you next week I am oof on
Thursday so that's a very implicit way
of saying I'm not available on Thursday
so in both these cases I can meet next
week except Thursday and you know
breaking it into two sentence where you
have the implicit we have seen you're
unavailable the concept of negation is
something you know that is very
important for us because those are the
times you do not want the meeting to
arrive
yeah and that's something you know again
we are collaborating with MSR and we
also have our homegrown solutions that
we are trying to do better at right all
right all right
we're talking about people right how do
we get bodies in a room and if it's a
phone meeting that's one thing but let's
talk about other resources for a second
because it isn't just people it's how
many people is whether the rooms are
available for example there might be
people from other buildings that need to
come so what about these other resources
yeah you bring up a very good point
about location intelligence right so
resource booking is such an important
part of meeting scheduling imagine
having a meeting time but then not a
room right I mean how often do we change
the meeting time because a conference
room is not available all right so
that's really crucial
so we also support conference room
booking resource booking so you know as
an user you can just say that hey book a
room for me or book a room in building
32 or in building 99 right and the agent
will then extract the intent that you
need a room and then the entities
associated with that intend that oh it's
supposed to happen in building 99 or if
you don't say something we just go with
your you know most recently used or
preferred rooms you are you can specify
that to the agent a list of your
preferred rooms say our VP's mostly
they'll have their own preferred rooms
you know reserved rooms so you can also
do that version with the agent and then
we try to book your room and if you're
not able to find a room you know we just
tell you we were not able to but
internally what we try to do is we try
to find a time when a room is available
and so the ranking algorithm changes
because now it has a different
constraint to it which that it requires
a room I was just going to ask you about
constraints because each layer is a new
constraint and I would hope as a person
I would be yeah I get that and I know
they're all here in building 99 and blah
blah blah but there's somebody from over
in 32 that needs to come over here
yeah travel time is something that we
haven't started supporting yet but
that's you know one of our biggest
things that we want to invest in and you
know we want to solve because the agent
should be intelligent enough to say that
oh yeah all they are free from 11:00 to
12:00 you have a meeting till 11:00 in
building 99 you cannot make it a day
right so we need to give that travel
time for meetings so today we don't have
that intelligence in our system well
let's talk a little bit about where you
are with this because that leads in
really well to my question about
automation and you have a wonderful
explanation for levels of automation and
where scheduler lives now and where
you're heading by tackling the problems
we're just talking about so let me first
you know for our audience give a brief
about the levels of automation so that
everybody is on the same page so we draw
the analogy from automation in cars
right so in the automobile industry the
Society of automobile engineers they
have done a great job in creating this
levels right let me go through the level
zero is like you know you are in
complete control there is no
intelligence you know no assistants
nothing level one is like most smart
cars so you're still in complete control
but you have some assistants right level
2 level 3 is more the assistance is
increasing you can get you know sensors
when you have a blind spot or your
wipers turn on automatically when it's
raining again you're doing less to do
more and then level 4 you're slowly
giving away delegating more and more of
the task of driving to the agent but you
are still in control you can respond if
there is an emergency and level 5 you
are just in your back seat and sleeping
autopilot yeah autopilot there you go
so in terms of your personal agents
that's where the spectrum is right and
we are probably at level two right now
right so I think this framework is
applicable to more than scheduler or
anything intelligent because I feel it's
a great
wait to set user expectations right so
imagine if I went to buy an intelligent
car and I didn't know where in the
spectrum it falls and I bought a level 2
car expecting it's a level 5 car I'll be
disappointed right or angry but if I
knew that I'm buying a level 2 car I
know what I can expect
similarly with digital assistance so
many of our users you know in the
initial days they would expect scheduler
to do things which it's probably a level
5 expectations so for example can you
reschedule a different meeting on my
calendar to accommodate this meeting we
don't support that right but they assume
as because humans can do that human
admins can do that when you share your
calendar with them when you give them
access they can go to your calendar and
reschedule meetings right that's a level
5 we don't support that
so we did sense frustration from people
because they were not aligned with what
the technology was when the product was
so this gives us a great way to align
our product you know and where we are
with the user expectations because a lot
of happiness in using something or doing
something comes from having direct
expectations I'm loving your phrase we
don't support that I think I'm going to
start using it instead of I can't do
that I don't support that
[Laughter]
[Music]
scheduler is literally a poster child
for tech transfer stories give us a
short biography of the project in your
association with it
where was it born where does it live now
and where is it in the pipeline to
shipping so I can use it yeah so you
learned back then started as calendar
would help it started in the future of
user social experiences lab also known
as the fuse labs at Microsoft Research
as I said earlier it started as a you
know Giga Konami platform to help
executive admins but then the original
team quickly realized that you know
scheduling is a big opportunity in that
domain and that's where it was born I
joined the team in October 2016 and that
was when Microsoft acquired geni which
was a startup in the Bay Area and this
was founded by my current manager
charles and his co-founder Ben and
Microsoft record genie and the goal was
that we will transfer this over to
Microsoft Outlook and if we become a
product there I didn't know where the
project was going you know I heard about
the announcement and I read about genie
and I read about cancer dot help I
didn't know about these projects or
these tools or anything and I just
wanted to be a part of it yeah so where
is it now in the pipeline yeah so we
have been in a public preview program
since November of 2016 and last ignite
November 2019 we announced we are going
GA sometime this year well the core
technology behind scheduler seems like
it could have other applications you've
actually kind of alluded to that already
how could you envision using the core
technology that's behind this beyond
calendars and scheduling yeah I think
the core technology is about
understanding intent in natural language
and today we only support emails as a
written form of natural language but it
can be spoken right and also
understanding context and preferences so
if I had to layer these right the first
would be understanding intent second is
how do you extract the right information
knowing the intent of an user and then
how do you find out what their
preferences would be in that context and
then get
the job done great and that can be
applied to so many things reserving
restaurants finding the right times to
meet your family or you know when
everybody's available you know there are
a myriad of scenarios where you can use
that well we've talked about what gets
you up in the morning but this is the
part of the podcast where I ask what
keeps you up at night
so I think about the work you're doing
helping the assistant list among us get
more done with their time even if we're
doing less by achieving more and that
all feels good to me
but I'm sure there are some consequences
intended or otherwise that might need to
be addressed so what kinds of things
keep you up at night and what are you
doing about it yeah so there are really
two areas that makes me anxious about
you know the progress we are making and
what we can do better so one is
definitely you know privacy user privacy
and ethics and what I think is currently
termed as compliance constraint AI right
you have to put the users privacy as a
first class citizen in everything you
are doing so I think that's definitely a
big area where I know many many many
teams and Microsoft is investing and I
think we have a long way to go there you
know how can we build even powerful
models but making sure that we are
honoring the privacy of the users right
and I think the second bucket is more
about user education and how can we
bring something intelligent but so
seamless for people to use who might not
know anything about tech right there are
all these complex pieces that we are
building together but how do you make it
very easy for people to start using it
and I'll give the context of schedule
itself right many times when say the
organizer of the meeting you know they
have cc'd katana and katana had reached
out to the invitee saying that hey you
know something I need this information
from you many a times those invite
people who receive that email from
Gautama I do not know how to react to it
should I should I write an email it's an
agent it's a bot like you know what
should I do with it right so it doesn't
scale for us to go one-on-one and tell
everybody here you know how you use the
product right so how can we make that so
seamless because in the
the service itself is so complicated
right but then how do you just almost
like flip the coin and the person who is
using it or is on the other side of not
just the user but you know the invitees
of the meeting or anybody involved you
know in the service to them it's feels
seamless I feel that is very cold and
today I feel that a lot of missing parts
where we could do more
well it's story time Pamela and I would
love to hear yours tell us a little bit
about yourself what cut you started
along the path to automating my
scheduling problems and how's you
learned about Microsoft so I came to the
United States to get my PhD and along
the way I added an internship at
Microsoft and I got a full time offer it
was more a personal decision at that
point to join Microsoft because me and
my husband you know my boyfriend at the
time we were in a long-distance
relationship for almost six years and he
got an offer from MSR and we felt like
you know this was a great opportunity
for us to be together
and the reason I say that is there was
no Applied Science role eight years back
at Microsoft you know data machine
learning yeah these were not you know
first class citizens that as a company
we were looking at or investing in so I
didn't really know how my muscle that I
built at grad school during my PhD would
be useful here but luckily for me you
know in almost like 1/2 years after
joining Microsoft we had this applied
science role and that's you know how I
started with this team I was talking
about earlier as the first person the
first hire on the team where we wanted
to use machine learning and AI to
transform customer interactions and
customer support in office 365 so I
believe it just worked out for me in
that way in like how I always wanted to
be an applied researcher so that was
about how I came to Microsoft and found
a role that I really enjoy doing on a
day to day basis and then you know about
scheduler I saw the announcement over
email you know when Microsoft has an
accusation they usually send an email to
the larger org this we are investing in
this and I found out and you know I was
very lucky that my VP got of who is the
VP for Outlook he introduced me to
Charles who is my current manager and
you know because I was so interested in
working in this space and things just
happened from there I mean yeah so where
did you do your doctorate from
University of California Riverside
so you started in India undergrad and
everything where in India were you
living so I was born and brought up in
the suburbs of Calcutta and my my family
now moved to Calcutta but yeah I was
born there and I think again it ties so
much back to how much my family believed
in STEM education and my parents you
know from a very early age they made
sure that you know education is
important math is important and actually
my dad I believe was more interested for
me to pursue computer science and both
my parents actually I then I don't think
I knew what it meant you know when I
signed up for coding classes and but I
enjoyed it you know and I think that's
how things went what's one thing people
might not know about you whether it's a
personal characteristic or a life
defining moment or a personality trait
or a sidequest
that may have influenced your decision
to become an applied scientist so I
think I did not start thinking I'll
become an applied scientist right what I
did know is that I had a lot of role
models right like people I wanted to be
like and I wanted to make an impact the
way they were making right and I think
that all these people that I really
admire it took them a lot of hard work
to get there what we often think of like
somebody is naturally good at it but
they have put in a lot of effort to get
there so that was one thing and the
second thing is that if I role model
someone I don't have to be exactly what
they are doing I have to kind of extract
out what in them do I really appreciate
and how can I build that muscle so I
felt like it was more about what are
they doing and how are they doing and
how can I apply that to my scenario and
take it from there so I think that the
inter lysing that
to me in my bad falls it sounds like
you're pretty analytical about things
it's funny you say that because my
manager told me the same thing in my
last connects because we're talking
about a very different problem like not
even with the product and he said you
know family analogy yeah I guess I am
yeah as we close and I'm sad to close
because it's so delightful talking to
you yeah thank you
I want to give you the opportunity to
talk to your grad school self the one
who didn't know where her career path
would take her and would love some
advice from her future self so what
would you say to you and by extension to
those in our audience who are where you
were then right now I think perseverance
is really important and sometimes we
don't realize even people who we know is
really successful how much failures they
have gone through and I feel dad is
something that I would tell my younger
self is just coming back every day and
trying to set the right expectations
from yourself being kind to yourself and
whatever your dreams are you should go
for them and you should just keep doing
it and not give up yeah not give up this
reminds me of a phrase I've heard that I
really like success isn't permanent
failure isn't terminal absolutely yeah
yeah that's great that kind of
summarizes Pamela Bhattacharya thank you
so much for joining us today it's been
an absolute delight thank you it's an
honor thank you very much okay
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Pamela
Bhattacharya and how researchers are
working to make life easier for people
who don't have people visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]